The semantics of sending a message
versus calling a function, is related to
what happens behind the scenes in
Objective C when a method is called.
The method, object message send,
which belongs to the NSobject class,
is called every time a message
is sent to an object.
Object message send is
not called until runtime.
Consequently the relationship
between the message and
the receiver is not
resolved until runtime.
This is in contrast to what happens and
swift.
In swift, a function call binds
a particular implementation of a method,
to a particular instance
of a type at compile time.
Then the message and its receiver
are not bound until compile time is
the principal difference between sending
a message and calling a function, but
for our purposes, it's primarily
just a difference of vocabulary.